for claiming juneteenth national freedom  day in our state to commemorate the end  of slavery he says it's a time to mark  the significant moment in history and to  also pay tribute to the culture of the  black community he also says quote there  is still a lot of work to do in our  fight for equality now is the time to  renew our commitment to be a better  nation and denounce hate racism and  bigotry that is still prevalent  the governor also joining the discovery  children's museum and observing  juneteenth this weekend there's going to  be a day-long event happening on  saturday it'll feature special speakers  they're going to have some workshops art  workshops a dance performance it all  starts at ten o'clock runs until five  again that's happening this saturday so  hopefully we'll have a nice forecast as  we head into father's day soon